jean christophe buisson on avait dit
qu'il y avait eu un moment populiste
avec le break site avec avec l'élection
de trump aux états unis et puis
qu'ensuite il y avait une sorte de coup
d'arrêt les élections législatives aux
pays-bas où finalement les crèmes droite
d'arrivée un score plutôt décevant
l'élection d' emmanuel macron en france
alors même que marine le pen était
considéré comme étant incontournable
entre guillemets ça veut dire quoi ça
repart là mais ce n'est jamais reparti
c'est à dire que nous on a tendance à
regarder ce qu'il ya autour de nous
parce que on est le noyau dur de
l'europe telle qu'elle a été créée dans
les 50 donc on regarde souvent ce qui se
passe en italie en allemagne au grand
compte un éventuellement un peu en
espagne et on se rassure à peu de frais
mais l'europe aujourd'hui c'est une
trentaine de pays et quand vous regardez
tout l'est de l'europe le moment le
moment populiste peux vous dire qu'il
perdure il faut dire qu'en croatie le
parti nationaliste est très fort je peux
dire que la hongrie de monsieur sorbonne
sorbonne il est à 50 % dans les sondages
50% de satisfaits que sa satisfaction
aujourd'hui si une élection
présidentielle en grille demain sorbonne
est réélu et d'autres organes comme une
vision assez nationalistes des choses en
ce moment en pologne de la même façon
j'aurais au pouvoir c'est un parti assez
conservateur donc ce moment vos
playlists il perdurer encore une fois le
miracle était que l'allemagne échappé
jusqu'à maintenant parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de raison objective pour
que pour que l'allemagne échappent à
cette cette ambiance générale de crin de
de crainte de voir effectivement des
valeurs asiatiques pour terminer merkel
avait aussi ouvert un boulevard à
l'extrême droite parce qu'elle a fait
campagne vous avez vu hier soir là ce
slogan qui était de 10 mythes le centre
à l'aff est l'as fait campagne sur le
centre donc forcément quand on fait
campagne sur le sens et pas vous voyez
vraiment sur son site
des mâles 60 selon le moins vrai voilà